Joey Graceffa has already reached
youtube superstardom and was on the New
York Times bestsellers list but he's
back with his first young adult novel
children of Eden
how excited are you I know you've been
working on this for what like two years
now it's been a process but I'm so happy
that it's finally done and I'm so
[ __ ] nervous are you able to read it
because it's like permanent it's not
like online where you can like delete us
like there are thousands of copies
around the world like you can't
disappear from that the book takes place
in a dystopian future where the
government limits one child per family
so it follows a girl who's born a twin
and her family decides to keep her
hidden so her whole life is just like
hidden behind these walls and um one
night she just can't take it anymore and
the story unfolds from there it's so fun
like just getting to bounce around at
different worlds and stuff going from
like murder mystery to like dystopian
yeah so like also working on storyteller
she's into like I have like three
projects that I'm like okay wait no
there's no magic in this world I have a
couple fan questions already so what I
would do it we mentioned you have brown
hair now yeah uh Kelsey wants to know
have you ever regretted dyeing your hair
a certain color and you've had a lot of
them you had so many okay I do regret
getting my facial hair colored I dye it
green and it just burnt I didn't realize
like the fumes were so close to my face
like it all hurt Oh Kristen wasn't no
you and Daniel are so cute and I think
you're also so cute what's your favorite
thing about being in a long-term
relationship um you know I've been
single my whole life he is my first
boyfriend it's just nice to have someone
that you can rely
ah man like if you're sick you can take
care of you I make you breakfast in the
morning oh isn't that what we all like
uh isn't that what we all want what
advice you have for single guys like I
don't know this guy make sure that
you're ready with yourself because I
feel like a lot of people try to get
into relationships when they're not
fully ready themselves and that I think
subconsciously makes anything fail